louis daniel burst homme de la liste
transition transmission un avenir pour
tous arrivent en tête lors des dernières
élections à la chambre d'agriculture et
dans son caddie ce matin avec nos
bonjour monsieur bertheaume
bonjour monsieur violent et bonjour à
toute la martinique d'abord l'actualité
immédiate cette mobilisation cette
nouvelle mobilisation de la soupe à marc
cette fois ci au quartier génie pas à
ducos contre l'installation
d'entreprises sur des terres agricoles à
sept dossiers récurrents qui revient
c'est régulièrement sur sur la qualité
et le goût d'aller bertone absolument et
il faut il faut se rappeler que depuis
des années nous militons pour que les
terres agricoles soient sanctuarisés
notamment au travers de deux abris de
zone agricole protégée et cette action
montre que effectivement on continue à
dilapider des terres agricoles et c'est
pas acceptable
quel peut-être le pouvoir de la chambre
de la culture de tels dossiers la chaîne
n'a pas beaucoup de pouvoir sauf à
donner des avis et sur ce dossier là en
tout cas sur le le plus de ducos la shdm
avait donné un avis défavorable parce
que nous estimons qu'il ya trop de
télévision de terres agricoles qui
partent sous le béton alors président
sortant de ses chambres d'agriculture et
très certainement président réélu à la
chambre consulaire ce serait pour quand
ce soit pour la semaine prochaine donc
les invitations dois partir je pense
aujourd'hui ou demain aura pas de
suspense là ce sera l'eau daniel
bertrand on est on est dans une élection
est donc temps que l'élection n'est pas
passée on peut pas on ne peut pas se
dire vous êtes bien placés comme moi et
dans le milieu sportif pour savoir que
tant que le match n'est pas joué
les cieux n'est pas connu revenons sur
le scrutin lui daniel berten puisqu'on a
annoncé les médias en dhr annoncé un
taux de participation de -2 22%
pourquoi une telle participation
seulement on a envie de dire
alors faut savoir que le la composition
de la chambre mais il ya plusieurs
composantes un peu comme ça nous avons
plusieurs collèges il ya une dizaine de
collèges et le collège principal qu'est
le coller des exploitants agricoles
le taux de participation était autour de
37 que tu pousses un essai acceptable
septembre je pensais au niveau de la
martinique parce que les gens ne se
mobilise pas nécessairement il faut
aller au devant des électeurs pour
qu'ils votent
et puis nous avons d'autres collèges qui
sont qui sont quelquefois un pas autant
mais où les gens ne se mobilise pas
beaucoup c'est les anciens exploitants
les salariés également n'y a pas eu de
trou de deux essais il n'y a pas eu un
taux de participation de 15 à potentiel
c'est sous ces collégiens et ce qui fait
que effectivement lorsqu'on l'ensemble
des électeurs de la chambre
d'agriculture le taux était très faible
est ce qu'il faut à ce jour dire que ça
peut être un axe de travail convaincre
que la chambre est un outil de travail à
condition de se l'approprier skhira pas
tout ce travail de communication peut
être à faire ou de propagande auprès de
toute cette famille agriculture
absolument absolument et c'est ce que
nous avons répété pendant cette campagne
cette campagne c'est qu'il faut
absolument qu'on fasse un gros travail
au niveau de tous ceux qui gravitent
autour du monde agricole autour de la
chambre d'agriculture notamment et
notamment les syndicats agricoles et que
ce soit les syndicats d'exploitants
agricoles que seuls les syndicats de
salariés aussi parce que c'est eux qui
vont faire grimper un peu le taux de
participation parce que c'est eux qui
vont aller informer les gens sur le
terrain
la chambre d'agriculture a deux grandes
missions c'est une mission de
représentation du monde agricole et une
mission d'accompagnement d'encadrement
des agriculteurs ben si on nous n'avons
pas le lait les autres c'est qui qui
fassent leur boulot notamment
d'animation
on n'ira pas loin se trouvait là se
trouvait là l'équipe que que nous avons
mis en place en tout cas que nous allons
mettre en place de voies s'atteler à ça
lorsqu'il faut bien entendre ce qui a
été dit pendant la campagne et que la
chambre la chambre d'agriculture a
failli à ses missions les agriculteurs
ne se sentent pas représentés
est-ce que vous avez bien entendu ça
j'ai bien entendu ça j'ai bien entendu
jamais jeudi également qu' il faut pas
que les gens se trompent sur les
missions qui sont alloués lâche maggie q
je le dis et et beaucoup de gens ont
entendu la chambre sur des missions des
missions qui sont pas ils sont par le
ciel de défendre le milieu agricole
c'est pas le boulot de la chambre par
exemple le le sujet que vous venez
d'évoquer la tout à l'heure sur le
problème de la défense des terres
agricoles
c'est pas la mission de la chambre
d'agriculture c'est la mission des
syndicats qui doit faire ce boulot là
sur des poèmes claude ecken on a entendu
beaucoup la chambre d'agriculture tout
ça c'est pas sa mission de faire ça sa
mission est d'accompagner les
agriculteurs sous le terrain et faire un
travail mais c'est pas sa mission dans
les défendre
la profession agricole sur ça mais
l'objet quoique tellement d'ampleur que
la shdm a dit la chaîne de la culture ne
peut pas rester silencieuse sur la
question des connes bien sûr que non et
l'ajustement la chambre a guide to se
fait entendre
nous avons et je pense que l'équipe
actuelle devoir s'atteler à ça nous
avons plein de communication sur le que
nous avons travaillé à la fin de l'année
dernière et donc nous devons mettre
compte cette année sur pour dire à la
population qu est ce que nous faisons et
comme nous le faisons au niveau de la
chlordécone parce que là aussi nous
avons besoin de nous fait rentrer nous
avons besoin de faire entendre la
population ce qui est mis en oeuvre
propos recueillis par claude ecken dans
leur assiette
alors que l'émotion vu les mois couru
suscité par cette molécule chlordécone
est est ce que qu'est-ce que vous voulez
mettre tout de suite sur pied concernant
ce se pose de ce problème je les dis
hein c'est d'abord informer les gens
pour qu'ils sachent que quel type
d'informations parce qu'aujourd'hui ce
qui ce que recherche martinique et c'est
de savoir si le produit acheté quel que
soit le lieu est propre à la
consommation ça c'est ça il ya des
choses qu'il faut qu'il faut qu'on fasse
c'est dire comment nous produisons com
ou au niveau du jeu et et puis il ya
aussi un travail qui doit être fait je
crois que le préfet l'a dit il va mettre
ça en oeuvre sur le plan chlordécone 4
notamment
c'est un peu plus de contrôles notamment
sur les marchands la chaire formelle sur
le marché informel il faut avoir
absolument qu'on arrive à faire en sorte
que tous les lieux de vente de produits
agricoles soient complètement sécurisé
et c'est aussi la mission de la sonde
habitude de faire connaître aussi tout
ça et il faudrait avoir le courage de
dénoncer ceux qui ne jouent pas le jeu
ab ce petit à prendre des sanctions mais
bien sûr ça je le suis aujourd'hui les
problèmes de la profession
on va revenir rapidement là dessus à lui
daniel berten vivre de son métier avoir
des conditions dignes acceptable de
travail les risques sanitaires la
retraite ça fait beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup ça fait beaucoup et des
agences est essentiel d'ailleurs le
titre de de notre lisbonne transition
transmission un avenir agricole pour
tout ça veut dire que nous estimons que
beaucoup d'agriculteurs n'ont pas
d'avenir en ce moment parce qu'ils sont
pas impactés par les par les mesures d
aide par
toute la politique publique qui ce qui
est mis en place pour pour l'agriculture
il faut absolument que tous les
producteurs puissent être accompagnés et
surtout avoir des moyens pour travailler
nous voyons la production diminué nous
voyons le nombre d'agriculteurs diminué
et ça c'est pas acceptable il faut
absolument que les politiques publiques
qui sont mis en oeuvre soit en accord
avec ce que nous donne ce qu'on nous
demande une demande de produits pour
nous et la population
ben il faut mettre en oeuvre les
politiques publiques pour cela oui mais
vous avez bien entendu vivre de son
métier des conditions les risques
sanitaires
la retraite s'il faut faire un choix
parce qu'on peut est ce que c'est
possible de mener toutes toutes ces
combats là en même temps est-ce qu'on a
les moyens humains financiers par
exemple on n'a pas la nappe allait
nécessairement les moyens financiers et
la chambre d'agriculture a des doutes
sur son financement en ce moment faut
savoir que la chambre d'agriculture est
financé à 60% +2 60% pas de la finance
publique par des subventions et à ce
jour nous sommes en attente de réponse
pour 2017 2018 bon il faut il faut qu'on
qu'on ait des réponses cependant ces
dossiers là doivent être quand même mené
il faut absolument que c'est par exemple
sur le plan sanitaire notamment sous les
pour les cultures
nous travaillons avec d'autres un
puisque ce travail là n'est pas menée
uniquement par la chambre d'agriculture
sur la mise en place de deux fonds
d'indemnisation lorsqu'on connaît
d'aider des risques lorsqu'on a des
catastrophes sanitaires des calamités
sanitaire en martinique on a vu la
destruction de plantations de fait de
pépinières de d'agrumes l'agriculture ne
n'est pas indemnisée donc nous
travaillons sur la mise en place de ce
fonds là est un fonds qui existe au
niveau national il faut que la
martinique et l'outre-mer soit impactée
aussi pas cela très rapidement les
visées reçoit aujourd'hui les syndicats
agricoles pour qu'ils s'investissent
davantage dans le grand débat national
la profession en parle
ce serait peut-être l'occasion de faire
remonter toutes ces doléances mais
écoutez vous avez bien que le lycée a
été une liste sans étiquette
donc nous n'avons pas de relais
en tout cas pour notre alice pour
l'instant syndicale mais je pense que je
souhaite en tout cas que les syndicats
locaux ont fait remonter les
revendications notamment qu'ils ont qui
l'ont soutenu et les polymathique de
l'agriculture martiniquaise en tout cas
le salon de l'agriculture s'ouvre
bientôt et j'y serai et assure à ce
niveau là il ya des rencontres qui sont
prévues notamment avec le ministre
l'agriculture et je compte bien faire
remonter toutes les toons des
problématiques merci louis daniel berten
d'avoir été avec nous il y aurait encore
cinquante mille questions concernant ce
secteur de l'agriculture mais vous
reviendrez merci bonne journée à vous à
vous aussi merci
[Musique]